وضع المستشفى يرت له اطلع ولا مبنى على
اخوه ولا طابق على ماهوه القصر كان موجود
وحنا موجودين هنا الطوابق هذه كلها تدمرت
حتى الصيدليه راحوا حرقوا الادويه عشان ما
نعالج الجرحه هناك كان في صيدليه ولحتى
الان ما زالت متفحمه كلياتها تحموا
الادويه وحرقوا الدنيا كلها عشان حتى ما
نعار ولا ولا جريح ما تمكنا نعالج الجرحه
بسبب الوضع الكارثي اللي انت شايفه وكمان
دخلوا على المخزن هناك هي في كمان معي
المخزن كله هذا المخزن طبعا انحرق ولا ظل
اي نوع من العلاج نعالج فيه الجرحه للاسف
كانت الامكانيات بسيطه جدا جدا بقول لك
انه انتم في انفاق عندكم طب هذا مستشفى
انساني بنعالج فيه المرضى والجرحى والناس
كلها نازحه فيه كيف بصير في مكان زي هيك
باي دوله باي عالم صار عننا هذه المجازر
اللي انتم شايفينها للاسف هي الصيدليه
كانت صيدليه كنا نعالج الجرحه وهي المخزن
الادويه كمان حرقوا ضربوا قدين هنا وللاسف
في متور بشغل فيه المستشفى ادى كمان
لالتهاب الحريق في المكان الوضع اصعب ما
ي